Handy's part of this call yeah okay cool
really okay blog weird episode I don't
even know I don't even know if we have a
[ __ ] blog blog today how's it going
wanted to be here yes how come I love
the hustle I love the drive this is the
future you know digital content is
everything yeah I'm gonna be able to be
where the game's gonna be
yes exactly so I want to be eventually I
want to be able to be like a creative
director or like the next you know or
something like that but for you free
your Creator yes I create content video
yep video I started doing photography
kind of story recently because it's a
lot easier to be able to push content
that is photography
makes sense and I don't want to put out
low-quality stuff but you know how I
think about that oh yeah got any
thoughts I'll put everything just be
smart don't don't overthink it too much
cuz that will hurt you if you start
thinking everything's gotta be Spielberg
you're gonna lose cuz that's the next
game you're using an old game as a
barometer while you know you want to be
part of the new game understand yeah
keep that in mind because that is
absolutely Creators deathblow it's hip
hot you you just you know my content so
I tell hip hop kids they want to put out
one song a [ __ ] year it's not gonna
work
it's what tell creators like the
lighting and the sound doesn't have to
be perfect doesn't it did one you have
to make a 500 million dollar movie but
not a [ __ ] it's reimpose not one blog
real pleasure man
I wish you well have a great day okay
let me bounce love you see ya bye
I'm Joey go downstairs yeah I had a call
one five eight minutes ago oh cool
[Music]
Andy's part of this call yeah okay cool
really okay blog weird episode I don't
even know I don't even know if we have a
[ __ ] blog blog today called it it's
just [ __ ] vlog that I called it a blog
here's what I give a [ __ ] about this
would be a nice little short video
that's enough probably turned into a
three minute rant so stick with me here
I'm getting weirdly in tuned to my
kindness and and being a good person and
caring you've seen it on Instagram I
talked about an interview yesterday I'm
starting to try to understand where the
new Alfa business leader is gonna have
to really really settle into like how
nice of a person are they because I
think it's becoming and has always been
weirdly but becoming even more essential
a success which excites the [ __ ] out of
me number two I'm obsessed with
Instagram stories number three and the
ads within them so oh little right hook
from a main man Andy here search on
Instagram gifs right search Gary Vee
people are using them like they're
really cool yeah okay big right hook
let's go well actually the whole right
hook [ __ ] what do I care about I got
four DS in London [ __ ] four DS
in London March 8th it's gonna kill her
voice con voice cont'd co-maid
twenty-second that's gonna be [ __ ]
important we've got a sneaker coming
well that's gonna go hard we're gonna
[ __ ] try to make that a pre-sale get
[ __ ] ready leave a comment if you're
gonna [ __ ] pre sell that
London Toronto oh yeah bill pop-ups for
the crushing it sneaker really meet 600
pairs of these they're gonna be [ __ ]
thousand dollars on eBay and stock X
mark my words London Toronto London so
those are me three pop-ups that there's
all this information like aggregator
calm slash events yes so that's going on
first in line first in lines [ __ ]
gangster our facebook Messenger text
messaging to platform I gave away 50
personalized sign books a lot of people
used it right this is how many to give
away stuff all day long you're gonna be
seeing me in wine country next week
there's that Saturday 24th Wine Library
[ __ ] a lot of people yeah how many
people are you doing ok Saturday 24th
there may not be enough books so order
in the Amazon or go to what do we yes so
it's buy more ok let's we were at 300
what do you think it should be 700 a lot
of people already bought the book I
don't even mind libraries sitting with
[ __ ] crushing it's 500 500 okay so
we'll do that if that happen what else
is happening yeah I mean small
businesses don't want to do stuff with
the Vayner sports we're gonna put all
these URLs like Andy you'll help iris
like all these different URLs because
what the forum for Vayner sports people
that want to jam for these man that's
really changing the game businesses are
spending $10,000 guys the number one
thing that crazy there we talk to leave
is he saying he doesn't have a Facebook
but he is doing everything else if you
if you're doing over a million dollars a
year you should come to New York and our
London and March 8th and do a four DS I
I'm gonna talk a lot more about selling
and selling is about selling something
you believe in
I've been very quiet about vaynermedia's
for DS program cuz it's ten thousand
dollars it's not cheap for a consulting
session day for me because I come from
zero but [ __ ] watching all these
people making money like the people that
went to for dese and the [ __ ]
october/november every [ __ ] place I
go now like in Tampa you saw the guys
like like they're [ __ ] make the money
so I don't know [ __ ] it
so four DS [ __ ] and and if you
were in YouTube or Facebook if you're
watching us if you're not following me
on Instagram that is the fundamental
craziest decision of your career
it's a massive mistake it is the funnel
not only Twitter's exploding duty to
Twitter is getting important like I'm
weirdly way more into Twitter lately I'm
engaging my hat um I've always been
spying on Twitter but like I feel like
I'm really in it I feel like a lot of
people from it you notice actually throw
some right over Seth where's your audio
uh audio content like I want these audio
videos that you and [ __ ] Calvin and
Caesar and all you [ __ ] characters
promise me
[ __ ] Caesar like let's go let's make
them everyday let's go so I'm excited
about that very excited about the
podcast if you're not following my
podcast it's like you're not subscribed
to my podcast that is a fundamental
crazy thing in your life what else
should be won't be first in line first
in lines would be the big whiners like
if you don't know what person line is
like it's it's it's my mess just message
me on facebook and it automatically
replies if you just message me on
Facebook right now it automatically
replies anyway lots going on you just
call this the [ __ ] biz dev episode
perfect what else do we [ __ ] want
people to do by the book yeah book book
it's fundamentally the craziest thing
you're doing in your life what about
what about our set are we being serious
about I don't feel like we're being
serious enough about my Alexis scale are
we we're not promoting it and we're not
producing original content we're using
other content so let's make that fix
okay if you're a follow me on snapchat
it's a huge mistake cause I'm getting
more serious again
what do you feel ooh
the Monday to Monday Spotify playlist if
you have Spotify and you've not
subscribed to the Monday than Monday
playlist it's one of the craziest
fundamental things you're making a
mistake on in your life oh the wine club
I haven't thrown a brakeman I would
enjoy the wine club wait till you
[ __ ] see there everyone's getting
February out March is [ __ ] if you
just want a one-off the white looks
thing like if you want to sign up for
the wine club for one month make it for
March by the way iris I want this ed is
really funny like you are like all the
URLs below but like also like the wine
club is gonna be a dick like I think
it's a hundred sixty dollars worth of
wine for fifth what is it bit 5555
delivered no shipping I'm gonna put my
dad out of business
literally me getting hammered anyway
love you guys see ya
[Music]